some good news in the middle of what is
really just a horrible story the 29 year
old Waffle House murder suspect has been
captured and this is the guy I told you
about yesterday massive manhunt was
underway for this guy back story is that
he entered a Waffle House in Tennessee
very late Saturday night early Sunday
morning I guess depending on how you
think about it allegedly shot and killed
four people injured three others ended
up fleeing the Waffle House when another
29 year old 29 year old James Shaw came
out of the bathroom where he had been
sort of hiding out and ambushed the
alleged shooter when the shooting had
paused and the shooter was reportedly
sort of looking over his assault-style
rifle the assault the alleged shooter
rather fled and was eventually captured
yesterday afternoon he was first spotted
by a civilian in the woods behind an
apartment complex in Tennessee police
officer Kyle Williams then showed up
spotted him drew his weapon told the
alleged shooter to get down on the
ground which he did and about 10 minutes
went by from the initial civilian
spotting of the suspect and police
successfully taking him into custody so
in the immediate what was the motive we
don't know will we ever know the motive
I guess it's more likely than if he had
ended up dead right which often prevents
us from finding out what caused or
catalysed acutely a particular shooting
second question and this is one that has
started to get pretty dicey is was he
targeting minorities right not a hundred
percent clear
it appears that everyone that was killed
was black or Hispanic is that accurate
if so was it a coincidence was it
deliberate all questions that we don't
yet have the answers to that would then
get us to question number three which is
whether this is or isn't domestic
terrorism and of course the answer to
that question may be there may be an
official answer to that and then we may
also have sort of a more colloquial
discussion about what what we think the
answer to that question is
and then also sort of lurking in the
background of this is what happens to
the alleged shooters father and the
reason that I bring that up is that
after the alleged shooter trespassed on
White House grounds last year I
mentioned this yesterday he had his
weapons seized and those weapons were
eventually returned to the alleged
shooters father who then ultimately
returned them to his son one of which
was actually used in this shooting ATF
the Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco and
Firearms for Alcohol Tobacco and
Firearms has already said that yes the
father's actions might be a violation of
federal law and then we get to the next
issue which is the sort of overarching
one with these incidents which is that
we will have we already have if you look
online claims from the pro-gun right
that the only issue here is mental
illness that the guy was delusional
he believed Taylor Swift was stalking
him which suggests also more of like a
paranoid schizophrenia he believed that
he was a sovereign citizen and I wish we
could get all of the right-wingers to
say that any sovereign citizen is
delusional but of course that that's a
story for a different day but as usual
no focus at all from the right on guns
just a lone nut who was crazy and in the
background I think it's important to
remind you of something else this guy
was a believer in this sovereign citizen
right-wing stuff that's a huge concern
for organizations that track hate groups
the anti-defamation league the Southern
Poverty Law Center those individuals
generally are perceived to be
significantly emboldened by the current
administration and we have no idea right
now whether this particular alleged
shooters actions were influenced by his
sovereign citizen beliefs will we ever
know the answer to that I don't know but
what we already see is the pro-gun right
saying what difference do this guy's
politics make right what what difference
does it make if this guy was an
eco-terrorist left winger of course it
was not or a sovereign citizen sort of
patriot type
right-wing extremists what difference
does it make because in the end the only
thing that matters in mental illness and
we also by the way are seeing people in
our next story about another one of
these vehicular murder terrorist
incidents saying the same thing which is
the beliefs don't matter except when the
perpetrator is perceived to be a liberal
or a left-winger or a progressive or
Muslim and then all of a sudden the
beliefs are the most important thing and
it's not some lone nut acting out of
mental illness and yesterday when I did
the original story I told you April 22nd
2018 right that's Sunday that's the day
that this Waffle House shooting took
place I told you that that day there
were 67 total shootings most of which
you heard nothing about sort of to
provide some broader context for the
severity of the shooting and gun
violence issue that we have in the
United States yesterday was Monday April
23rd 2018 the day of this alleged
shooters capture the shootings continued
there were 43 shootings that took place
yesterday Monday April 23rd 2018 we hear
about a tiny number the small number
that make it into the media dialog but
there are endless shootings every day
and combine the numbers now right April
22nd this shooting took place April 23rd
consumed with a manhunt for the alleged
shooter who was eventually caught 67 and
43 shootings on those two days
110 shootings took place on the two days
that we were concerned nationally in
corporate media with the story of one
shooting and that's the broader tragedy
right the micro is what triggered this
particular guy the next layer is beliefs
domestic terrorism or not targeting
minorities or not and then the the sort
of highest level here is the just
absolutely drastic and disastrous
problem we have in this country with gun
violence 110 shootings taking place in
the 48 hour period during which we were
mostly aware most of us aware of just
one shooting story absolutely
horrible and a problem that we're not
really getting any closer to solving in
this country the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership